just a business to make sure that you
sure yeah here let's talk about that
because I really want to talk about
rejection sure because I think for for
every filmmaker I mean most people get
bummed out and they stop you know and
they go home they live lives of sadness
and bitterness and you know then they
have kids they take it on their kids
their kids work to be sad go to people
but you know generations you know it's
like you know so I mean it's important
remember that there was a frustrated
artist doing couldn't the people the
pies painting so he ended up you know
becoming this dictator we don't want
that we want any year people who's
anyone who sees this to do that so I
digress it's almost the Bible or why it
is well yes it's you know but again it's
like what are you doing it for it what
do you need and what's woody in it for
you know I mean we all have to be
applauded we all have to win and succeed
it's it's right it's very hard to lose
you know no let's talk about go for it
petti may be said that the twilight zone
campaign was rejected what 25 yes over
two year period it was rejected
it was particular ejected 25 times over
two year period and that's where it's
very important to have something called
a wife because Elaine said to me just
keep going just keep going and but also
when something's not working you have to
analyze why it's not working and fix
that because until you really figure it
out you can't change it and so what was
going on in that point was my book agent
was Rod Serling's book agent she had
been Rod Serling's book agents with
millionaire agents she represented Peter
Benchley he was doing jaws at that time
and so from so so she would submit the
book and the publishers it would say
well we like this but we don't have a
salad we know what this market for it
and she wouldn't be convincing them she
wouldn't be selling them on it and and
also it would be submitted to an older
editor or an editor who wanted to buy it
but then I have to go to an older
publisher who hadn't grown up with
twilights it wasn't a fan of the show
and we didn't understand why anyone
would be to book about a show that was
already off the network you know they've
been off the network for over a decade
so so I fired I fired her she was amazed
that little pipsqueak like me would fire
her but I did and I got another agent
and it was the agent who was coming
we've been in a book editor which is
starting a saying she was hungry and
she's young and aggressive and she went
back to where the publishers that are
rejected at Bantam she went to a
different editor of anymore when Apple
valve was a young you know amazing guy
just starting out but he had the power
to buy books he didn't have to go to
anyone from for permission he grew up
with the file eyes and he loved it so he
bought the books in the 26th submission
that sold and it was an instant
bestseller and it's been in print ever
since so but but rejection is very hard
which is why you need to surround
yourself with people who are supportive
of you it's cool allow your dream you
must also make sure that your work is
solid
if the film's have to be good most most
writing is not very good most phones are
not very good and you have to look at
that with a very hard and discerning eye
and and if you watch it and you say well
wait a minute these actors aren't very
good so maybe I need that's director to
learn how to work with actors and maybe
I need to go to better actors maybe I
need to well you care what tells a great
story because it all boils down to how
committed you are to your work and
Guillermo when he was doing Kronos first
of all is his writing teacher said to
him if a road is not presented you build
one and Guillermo in Mexico there was no
infrastructure to do the kind of movies
he wanted to make she spent ten years
building a makeup effects and special
effects company as a vendor to others so
he would make his first film Kronos and
then we were shooting shooting Kronos
there was one shot he wanted which is
the inside of this device with all his
gears and it's a little weird creature
in the center of that device he planned
to build it was about this big and there
be a little miniature camera that would
have a little little cable that would go
and move around in this little thing
and this producer said we do not have
the money to make that shot
you're gonna have to lose that shot and
dermal really want that shot so what he
did was he sold his van and he didn't
have the money to do that shot but we
did that money too was there was a
junkyard and they had these enormous
gears from some factory that were the
size of a room we bought those gears and
painted little gold we made this big
creature that was like the size of a
Volkswagen we put in the middle of those
gears and then he actually had the
full-size camera move between those
things so if you ever see that shot it
supposed to be this big and was actually
the size of a room but that was
Guillermo willing to sell his van to get
that shot so question with anything
you're doing is how committed are you to
what you're doing and you have to be
very committed and because you might be
rejected 25 times but my play six
that magic will happen and doors will
open and a cure will be made and but you
also have to be willing to have that
happen again and again and again and and
it and anytime you say it shouldn't be
this way what you have to say instead is
it is this way what am I going to do
about it and that's how it works do you
think it's harder to break into
business or maintain
in terms of breaking into the business I
view myself as a burglar working a
neighborhood where I have to keep
breaking in and breaking in and breaking
in so it's not one it's not just once
and it's not like all of a sudden you're
through the golden door and you know
you're serving you pate
it's basically it's you know it's like
it's coming up with things staying fresh
finding the things that excite you of
being open to the world learning new
things telling new stories not just
going over the same material over and
over again recognizing what you love
I mean Ray Ray Bradbury was very good
with that heat everything he loved
she kept he kept what he was a kid he
was collecting with Buck Rogers
newspaper scripts this comic strip and
some kids ridiculed him and he threw out
his collection and he realized he made a
terrible mistake and he spent years
building that collection back up and
it's funny because as an adult he was
once speaking somewhere like in Big Bear
and someone said to him I have I
collected those two and I can give them
to you if you'd like them any in got
them and and so from him I learned to
honor what you love and and come from
that place and really recognize your own
unique qualities because that's what
makes you an individual as an artist so
but again it's you know you're gonna get
knocked back and you're your biggest
dreams are gonna fall to disaster and
you just gonna be moments where you just
wanderings you know as if you've been
you know sucker-punched and you know and
that's again when you must have people
who know what what they're doing and you
call them you say okay I'm lost here
what do I do how do I do this and you
know because you don't go to people who
hire you and you don't say that the
people who hired you say if the friends
you've gathered over the years to know
what they're doing and that's where it's
so far and have mentors and and and
alpha it can be a two-way street so for
instance someone might be mentoring me
but they'll be an area that I know how
to do the Nadeau
row so here's how this works it's very
much
street
you